have you ever thought about having
another co-host besides Noel what do you
mean you and Noel have done the same
podcast for five years okay right isn't
it time to switch it are you trying to
are you trying to start a show no dude
no no I'm just saying aren't you
interested in that you never fantasize
about the idea of starting a podcast
with somebody else I mean I did I mean I
brought back insanely chill yeah right
it was just you that's just me but you
ever think about maybe you know if I
started it with you know a Wally
I don't know
well
hey God let me hear me out all right I'm
kidding by the way this has been really
fun I kind of like the way that you're
just like sporadic you're [ __ ] add
yeah here's why I think I would be a
great co-host for you let me go ahead
and uh run through this line so you're
wait you're pitching me no I'm just kind
of we're just casually there's a brand
new you got a PowerPoint presentation
it's just with sick animations too it's
just a casual okay let's read this for
the people that are listening hey Cody
that's the first slide
this is why
let me just yeah keep there's a lot of
animate each letter yeah I thought it'd
be fun keep you interested I will lead
okay
and the better co-host than Noel let's
pause on this for a second okay Noel
right has an L in his name that's true
you don't want that yeah that's you only
want W's okay Walid also hasn't well uh
W comes first and his name is literally
no else
your name is wow hey
no questions until then okay okay
um obviously on the goat okay yep so if
you just keep going to the next the next
slide there you go like the little
picture of the goat there thank you now
one thing I wanted to have you consider
is our dick size okay now I've seen
noelle's dick size okay it is huge right
my dick size in the in the other hand
what two three centimeters on a good
centimeters yeah dang okay now you gotta
think about the brand right do you want
a guy as your co-host tiny meat gang to
have the biggest [ __ ] in the studio yeah
I mean that is an issue or do you want a
guy who actually represents the brand
okay full body okay that's a good point
yeah sorry the eggplant emojis is yeah
that's how many did you put on there
it's not moving to the next screen
enough there you go there it is there's
a chart
so you see here obviously way bigger
okay Noel's packing 12 14. centimeters
still not that big sorry did I how big
centimeters again this is like that okay
I meant inches okay now let's move on to
the next slide because I I think this is
very important too I'm always in a silly
goofy mood yeah okay right we're hanging
out you saw how crazy I was yeah yeah
you are kind of whacking a while yeah
wacky Wally you are Milwaukee Wally yeah
yeah a little goofball yeah now Noelle
he's always kind of serious
he wanted to be fine you want to be
goofy so I have a chart here that
explains how goofy I am okay and how
kind of goofy Noel is silly goofy mood
percentage
I'm up you are up I mean and I do like
the cowboy that I mean that's [ __ ]
that's wacky in itself thank you I
worked hard on this yeah let's go to the
next slide here um now viewership okay
right
you've been doing the podcast for so
long you know sometimes you get in these
moments of like a lull you know you're
like well the podcast isn't it's just
not skyrocketed yep I think if you gave
me a chance we could I'm talking 40.
million views okay yeah yeah how and how
would you do that
um I would just I'll explain it actually
I said no question
both from the wacky and wild yeah so
yeah yeah people people are looking
exactly people are very receptive so I
actually reached out to a YouTube rep
and I said hey can you have ai generate
uh what views would look like and he
actually sent me back this chart this
morning holy [ __ ] I think you should
look it's very interesting that's insane
so that's you there at 40 million and
then if with Noel it's just it goes to
zero yeah unfortunately unfortunately
yeah uh let's go ahead and hit the next
this is AI generated yeah
and you can't can't really argue yeah
yeah it's real okay uh mutual interest
right we talked about some fun mutual
interest today we did yeah I love
running yep you love running yes right
he loves race cars boo what am I [ __ ]
eight years old
oh the car goes fast boring all right
you're winning me over you're winning me
over now I hate movies
yeah I think they're too long oh let's
go yeah okay what's your what's your
perfect movie length uh a tick tock
movie you've seen those yeah there's
like two minutes yeah so whatever now
what time do you like to go to sleep 8
30.
well I had to wake up early to cook the
goddamn that's true yeah that's true now
Noelle told me what's your favorite
college
um
brown brown
university of Brown town no I was saying
Duke right oh uh
uh yes you like Duke I I do why oh
because you I went there yeah yes I knew
that yes now Noelle actually told me he
hates Duke I know which I'm like dude
that's [ __ ] up yeah you're a co-host
goes to do that's messed up it's [ __ ]
up let's go over to the next slide real
quick
um now when you're working with a guy
like me okay I got some real celebrity
power I got some friends in the bids
yeah yeah I got some people I I will be
honest you are rather connected yeah I
am plugged up you are I was very
surprised like the first episode of foul
tip having Blake Anderson yeah that was
actually really cool
surprise he said yeah yeah I was like
damn this is High Caliber well here's
the thing they all love me because I'm
in a silly goofy mood all the time
that's true and now celebrities that I
know who do you know I know Mike Tyson
okay I know uh Nick Cage what yeah you
know uh Leonardo oh [ __ ] is that him
who's that Brad Pitt yeah
um Andrew Garfield
and Justin Bieber you know Justin Bieber
yeah I mean him how do you know him look
I also know Obama I know dude I was
talking to Obama on the way here really
yeah you don't believe me no I I'll just
I'll play a little voice note from him
so funny yeah he's my he's my dude I
gotta you know Tupac
yeah fun fact he is still alive
let me play you this voice note from
Obama this morning so funny I love that
guy what
Rock Obama here how's it going
just want to say I love you so much and
good luck
on your podcast I love you and I love
Cody
president
of the United States it's my dog man wow
dude I gotta I gotta be honest I'm
honored yeah that's amazing he's a huge
fan
no way yeah he says during you know all
the important meetings he had he'd watch
uh that's cringe no [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
I'm fine I'll bring him out next episode
I'm floored I would love that now Noel
uh who does he know right
Carrot Top does he I don't know he knows
he knows a guy that looks like Carrot
Top okay okay and then who else I don't
know [ __ ] you guys
that's not really a you're gonna be
running a cycle here you're gonna be
running around in circles so you're
saying noelle's not cool because he
knows us
no that's your argument no no I'm saying
oh I'm saying uh it's only you guys okay
you're not right you want to cast a
white net right you're doing a podcast I
mean I will say care top is pretty cool
we've been trying to get him on the show
I dm'd Kara top he read it and never
replied damn he follows you he doesn't
no damn I just dm'd him because I was
like I want him on the show what do you
say hey come on the show yeah I was like
hey I saw your I watched his Joe Rogan
episode I was like I really like he has
a joke one episode yeah it's really good
I swear to God it's [ __ ] good can we
remove Carrot Tops
thank you now the last point is I dude I
just love you thank you man you know
unconditionally unconditionally of
course with the fun animations yeah he
gave it means that could show yeah that
airs every Tuesday TFG Studios and if
you want to listen to ad free
tmgstudios.tv
um anyways just just just think about it
you know take your time no rush
obviously take the food home I I really
appreciate that
um
you're still not invited to the wedding
no I really appreciate that I'm gonna
seriously consider this offer yeah for
like how long you think how long will I
consider yeah I mean you know however
long it takes for me to reach a decision
what do you think it would be called if
we did a show silly goofy with Cody okay
yeah I like that not really okay what
would you call it
um Brown going to Brown town or what
about like something like um
yeah
like Maple brown or something like that
yeah I like that actually like that a
lot caramel yeah Brown snow
disgusting